- So hello everyone,
and welcome to "Academic
Jobs Outside the US."
This is the third and final
webinar in our three-part series
on Doing Chinese History in a New Era.
The series is organized by
Denise Ho at Yale University,
and myself, Emily Baum at UC Irvine.
We are very excited to be
broadcasting to you live
from the same location in
Southern California. Surprise!
And this webinar series has
been generously sponsored
by The Council on East Asian
Studies at Yale University
and the Long US-China
Institute at UC Irvine.
We are also very grateful to
our long list of co-sponsors.
We will just read their names
out very quickly right now.
They include Harvard
University's Fairbank Center,
The Center for East Asian
Studies at Stanford University,
The Project on China's Global Sharp Power
at the Hoover Institution,
The Center for Asian
Research at York University,
the Department of History
at Simon Fraser University,
the Institute of Asian Research
at the University of British Columbia,
The East Asian Studies
Program at Johns Hopkins,
Program at UC Santa Cruz,
The Global China Center
at Hong Kong University
of Science and Technology,
and the Hong Kong Institute
for the Humanities and Social Sciences
at the University of Hong Kong.
So just a couple of words
about how this session will
be run before we get started,
each presenter is going to
speak for about 10 to 12 minutes
and at the end of the session,
we will reconvene for a moderated Q and A.
You should all know this by now,
but if you have a question
at any point in the webinar,
please ask it using the Q and A button
at the bottom of your screen.
In total, this webinar will last
for approximately 75 minutes.
We are recording it
and we will be recording
only those panelists who
have agreed to be recorded.
But we will send out a
link to the YouTube video
in a follow-up email to all
registered participants.
So be on the lookout for that
if you can't make it
through the entire session.
- So, we designed this webinar series
with the goal of supporting
graduate students
and junior colleagues in
the Chinese Studies field.
Last year, one of our
webinars addressed the topic
of careers outside of academia,
and we'll drop that link into the chat.
And for that one,
panelists spoke about jobs
in government, non-profits,
and specialists books.
Based on the responses
to last years series,
we decided to dedicate
one webinar this summer
to the topic of searching for jobs
outside of the United States.
In this session,
we are lucky to be joined
by four scholars of China.
We'll talk about the
characteristics of the job market
where they're currently teaching,
what academic life is
like at their university,
and what challenges and opportunities
their academic systems present.
We hope that this panel will be of use,
not only to scholars of China,
but also to candidates on the job market
in a wide variety of disciplines.
To save time, we'll first introduce
all of our speakers briefly.
Our second speaker is Taomo Zhou,
assistant professor in
the School of Humanities
at Nanyang Technological
University in Singapore.
She is the author of "Migration
in the Time of Revolution:
China, Indonesia, and The Cold War,"
out with Cornell University Press in 2019.
Our third speaker, Mary Brazelton,
is university senior lecturer in
Global Studies of Science,
Technology and Medicine
in the Department of History
and Philosophy of Science
at the University of Cambridge.
She is the author of the book,
"Mass Vaccination, Citizens Bodies
and State Power in Modern China,"
Published by Cornell
University Press in 2019.
Finally, Charles Chang
is assistant professor
of Environment and Urban Studies
at Duke Kunshan University.
He specializes in Computation and Design,
and his publications include articles
in the Journal of Chinese
History, Political Analysis,
and Landscape and Urban Planning.
- Hello everyone!
I'm Taomo Zhou. I'm Assistant Professor
at Nanyang Technological
University in Singapore.
Thank you Emily and Denise
for organizing this event.
So I thought it's still unsafe
for many of us to travel,
So I thought I'd give you
a virtual campus tour at NTU Singapore.
So, here you see the
landmark of the University,
the Chinese Heritage Center.
So I start with talking a little bit
about my own experience.
So, I graduated from Cornell in 2015.
Went on the job market for two years.
I was very fortunate to
have jobs offers at the end,
but the whole process
had been emotionally and
physically very draining.
So very much echoing to what
Rovana said about relevance.
As Emily mentioned,
my first book is about China
and Indonesia in the Cold War.
So I was kind of in this,
in between place
between the feuds of modern
China and modern Southeast Asia.
Although we have seen a transnational term
for more than a decade, most of the jobs,
unfortunately in many parts of the world,
are still geared towards regional,
country-specific research.
So somehow in Singapore,
because of it's geographical location,
it's economic and strategy needs,
I was encouraged to kind of cross over
between China and Southeast Asia.
So Singapore has been my
intellectual home for six years.
One year as a postdoc,
and five years as assistant professor.
So for those of you who are
not familiar with Singapore,
I'm just going to briefly run through
the academic institutions.
So there are six major universities
and higher education institutions
all across the island state.
The National University of Singapore,
many of you probably have heard about,
is the flagship.
Has the most longstanding,
prestigious programs
in humanities and social sciences.
And of course, my own home institute, MTU,
will always try to challenge that.
UNUS College is physically
on the NUS campus,
but it's autonomous, independent,
liberal arts college.
And then, SMU is more
like a business school.
It's located downtown, right
at the center (indistinct).
And SUT I'm going to
talk about them later.
These are two new universities,
rapidly expanding their
humanities programs.
So if you've never been to Singapore,
would you pursue an academic career here?
So, first thing is that the
economic academic system
here is modeled on the United States.
What does it mean?
It means that basically
the job application process
is similar, right?
So now it says standard
job, talk, 45 minutes.
It's a interview with
the search committee,
which could be either all people
of your field at work.
In my case,
there were historians and
also social scientists
and the tenure application
process is also similar.
but the major difference
between Singaporean universities
and American universities
is that most of the institution here,
especially the humanities programs,
are very young.
They're kind of up and coming.
So what does it mean for
junior scholars like us?
I think it means like
it's very bottom heavy.
So when I joined my department
and there were only one
or two associate professor
and only one full professor,
so when we lost that full professor
and we're still doing a
search for a senior faculty
in Asian History Broadly Defined.
So it means that you
don't have many mentors
who could set your path.
You need to forge your own paths.
But the upside of that is that you have,
like a group of really brilliant,
dynamic young colleague.
And I'm really enjoying
brainstorming with my colleagues
in the department.
And it also means that,
basically you even got opportunity
as a junior faculty to
create your own program.
I think this is quite unique in Singapore
because the humanities fields
are growing very rapidly.
So I'm going to talk a little bit
about the job opportunities
available here.
So first, you see the campus of SMU,
Singapore, Management University and SSUS.
These two institutes are
probably not that well known
outside of Singapore, but they
are growing very, very fast.
They want to recruit international
talents very rapidly.
So how would they do that?
They will offer really attractive payment.
So for example, later on
you'll see a job advertisement
for education track faculty position,
just keep in in mind that that
is substantially different
from the adjunct positions
you're gonna have
in the United in the sense that
usually the salary is
internationally compatible,
it's definitely economically viable,
economically stable life in Singapore.
So I think on that, the
Singapore system is a lot better.
And also you might also see advertisement
for post-doctoral fellowships at ARI,
Asia Research Institute.
It's also part of the National
University of Singapore,
but it's kind of semi autonomous.
These kinds of positions,
you only start with a two
or three-year contract.
However, I seen many colleagues
who kind of smoothly transition
from, say, a short-term
post-doctoral fellowship
to a long-term research position.
So you won't be teaching,
but it's kind of like a
tenure track research-focused
position, which is also
economically viable and stable.
So now I'm going to advertise
for my own university.
So here you see our
signature building, The Hive.
It's also nicknamed
the (indistinct).
So NTU is located at the
far west end of Singapore.
We're almost in Malaysia.
So some of you might see the advertisement
for this Nanyang Assistant Professorship.
It's a really, really generous package
coming with one million
Singapore dollar research fund.
You can still apply to it.
The deadline is September 30th, 2021.
So this position has
been geared more towards
engineering and natural sciences.
However, recently we see
a very encouraging sign
that says that my
colleague, Florence Mark,
(indistinct)
so we're very hopeful
that public university
are going to channel more of
the funding towards humanities.
There's also the Presidential
Postdoc Fellowship.
So the call is currently
closed but will reopen again
in January next year.
It's a two year contract,
also coming with a very
generous salary research grant,
and I think there is also
relocation grant as well.
So, yeah,
would you move here if you
never been to Singapore?
How is it really like working here?
So I already talk about the
advantages, the upsides.
Some of the issues, from
what I heard from Rovana,
it seems like Singapore
system is quite similar
to the Hong Kong system,
in a sense that this is,
my university in particular is very tech
and science heavy university, right?
So as scholar of humanity,
you are constantly asked
to prove that your research
is valuable, right?
So this kind of anxiety led
to certain inflexibility
in terms of your publishing outlets.
Basically, my department
meticulously ranked
all the journals.
They do Tier 1, Tier 1A and Tier 1B,
and I have to send screenshots
of my Google scholar citation report,
for my annual evaluation.
So in other words, when I
talked to my colleagues,
I found that it's kind of similar
to the UK and Australia system,
but that's something I never heard about
when I was going through my PhD training
in the United States.
Similar to Hong Kong,
there are funding opportunities around,
however, in terms of
how to use the grants,
the faculty members had last autonomy.
So basically you have to meticulously,
meticulous budget,
itemize at all your grants,
and then when you're going to use it,
you have to show meticulous documentation
why you're seeking reimbursement.
So the paperwork is a bit daunting
and that's, I think, is
also very energy sucking
and it's a big time sucker.
So that kind of prohibit
many of my colleagues
from applying for research grants.
But having said that,
I will still say that
Singapore is a great,
great place for scholars like myself
who study Chinese migration,
and also because of Singapore's location,
there are lots of Greece scholars
in Southeast Asia and South Asia.
So that means it's also
a great place for those who
study intra Asia connections,
China-southeast Asia
relations, migration, China,
south Asia relations and migration.
And Rovana talk about a linguistic
environment in Hong Kong.
Similar in Singapore. Singapore
is a multi-lingual society.
So Mandarin, Malay,
and Tamil are all used.
So what does it mean for a China scholar?
It means that, basically,
you have a wider body of colleagues
that you can work with.
For example, at NTU and NUS,
there are Chinese departments.
It's a interdisciplinary program
with scholars of literature,
of course, of like science
and technology studies,
and also of history.
For example, in NTU history,
NTU Chinese department,
we have medical historian Fang Xiaping,
who also wrote about cholera,
someone you can work with.
And also it means that
you have more students
who have the capacity to work
on Chinese sources, right?
So it's easier in my case,
easier to recruit research assistant
who can help me process data in Chinese.
And in terms of access to
data in mainland China,
I will say that basically,
I think two minutes,
I'll try to wrap it up,
in terms of research
data in mainland China,
I think in the past,
field work is relatively easy.
So basically it's easy
to travel back and forth.
And also I feel like because
the political relationship
between Singapore and
China are more amicable,
my informants are more
relaxed, or less guarded,
when I tell them I'm a
scholar based in Singapore.
After COVID, I'm still trying to carry out
research through online book purchases
such as from (indistinct)
or collecting data
through my local partners.
I think international visibility
is the biggest challenge
because in the past you
have to do long haul flights
for 10 AHA or AAS, but after COVID,
lots of the events are moving to
Zoom, other virtual platform.
I feel like there are more opportunities
for international collaboration.
So that's the end of my presentation.
I look forward to comments and questions,
and I'll be happy to
talk about, for example,
how to balance life and work
in a place like Singapore.
Thank you.
- Okay.
So as Denise mentioned,
my name's Mary Brazelton.
I'm a senior lecturer in
the Department of History
and Philosophy of Science at
the University of Cambridge.
And if you're attending this session,
I'm guessing that you're
applying for a postdoc or possibly
a permanent academic position in the UK.
These comments will be
focused more on the latter,
simply because that's my experience.
So what it's like to
go through the process
of applying for it and then
taking up a lectureship
in the UK.
And I'll start by actually
talking rather a lot
about logistics before I move on
to talking about the academic life
and its challenges and benefits,
simply because I approached
this thinking about
what I would have liked to know
when I was at the point of
making applications like this.
So the first thing to note
is what a different structure of
academic life exists in academic careers.
So Taomo mentioned that
Singapore's educational system
is modeled on the US.
That's not so much the case for the UK,
and there's an entirely
different vocabulary of
job applications as a result.
So a lecturer, for example,
the starting point of a job
is an assistant professor in the US,
in the UK, it's a lecturer.
In the UK, traditionally
the title of professor
was a senior title that you
only received after a career,
a lifetime of publishing
and working in scholarship.
So there are useful
differences of nomenclature
to be aware of.
There's also, I think, a
pretty fundamental difference
in terms of the permanent nature
of lectureships in the UK,
as opposed to tenure
track positions in the US.
In the UK, job security is more
disconnected from
promotion and advancement.
So a lectureship that is permanent
has good job security, generally speaking,
but promotion is not guaranteed.
You have to apply for promotion,
sort of going through a round,
a series of,
of applications. That
is different in nature
than the tenure system in the US.
So I got my position in 2015,
and since then, I've sat on
several search committees.
So this has really informed for me,
my time on both sides of
that particular table.
One thing to know about applications
is that the timeline
for applying for and receiving
an academic job in the UK
works very differently.
Often, there's a much shorter period
between jobs being announced
and the interview's being held.
It's not necessarily conforming
to the academic calendar
that we're familiar with.
Another difference that I
found really fascinating
was the fact that in the UK,
the norm is that you have all
job talks on the same day.
And I was actually able to
attend all the other job talks
for the same position that
we were all applying for.
In the US, it's quite
common to be expected
to go out to dinner
with the people who are interviewing you,
in the UK, we were told as
job applicants and candidates
for the same job to go
and have dinner together
without anyone from the department along.
So a very different approach,
I think, to sociability
in that context of job applications.
The job talk was also very short.
It was 15 minutes,
and it was not as important
as the formal interview.
So the whole process
was held over two days
and the formal interview on day two
was a much more kind of formal panel.
Along with that,
there are significant legal
restrictions on what can be
asked in those formal
interviews in front of a panel.
Most of the questions
in that interview were,
I would say, pretty similar
to what you might get
in interviews for a North
American job in academia.
One crucial difference
though I think is that
demonstrating your ability
to get external grant funding
is more important,
and that's because of a
particular difference between
North America and the UK in
terms of getting funding,
both for your research and for
your postgraduate students.
So in the UK, postgraduate students
who are working towards PhDs
are often supported by external grants.
So not university funding,
but fellowships or projects.
Likewise, the research that academics do
is often supported by grants
that they have applied for
that can be several years in duration
and can run into the millions
of pounds or euros in value.
And so often at the point of application,
it's really good to know that
that is part of the system,
that in many cases, as
an academic in the UK,
you will be expected to
apply for, and receive,
extensive funding from
a variety of agencies,
some of which I've put on the slide.
And this is in part because
there aren't necessarily always
a lot of research funds
available to universities
and so career advancement, in many cases,
is tied to your ability to think
in a way that will be
conducive to getting really big
scale funding and grants
that will support not
just your work, but postdocs
and PhD students for years.
Now, if you get to the point
of negotiating a position
and preparing to actually come to the UK,
I think it's probably worth knowing
that there are some key differences
between North America and the UK system
in terms of what's possible to negotiate
and what's desirable
as a new
starter in a position here to negotiate.
So it may be quite difficult
to negotiate on base things
like salaries, but there are other things
that are quite important to consider.
Notably, I would call
attention to visa fees.
I think I've missed a slide
here, but that's fine.
In my experience, relocation
packages are really generous,
but in some cases you have
to pay for your own visa,
which can amount to thousands
of dollars or pounds.
So if you're offered a
job and you can negotiate,
ask whether the department
will cover those fees.
Just to give you a sense,
I ran the numbers and I found that
to go from receiving a job
and starting a work visa
to the final point of
getting permanent residency
and even citizenship in the UK,
that total amount is about
8,000 to 9,000 pounds.
So about 10,000 US dollars.
So it's something that if
you can get your university
to pay for it, and some
universities will do this,
that would be extremely desirable.
Also, there are other aspects of logistics
that I'd be happy to talk
about in the Q and A,
but I have a timer
and I see that I'm quickly
running out of time
so I'd like to transition
to talk a bit more about
some of the less tangible
aspects of jobs in the UK.
So first, just some
interesting differences
of academic life.
It was really fascinating
to move to the UK
and realize that certain concepts
and conceptual frameworks
could be very, very different.
So in the UK, empire matters hugely
as a category of historical analysis.
And in some respect,
studies of non-Western regions
or histories can be assumed,
or even just read as studies of empire,
and especially of British empire.
This has been interesting to navigate
as a historian of China,
especially as British universities
embraced projects of decolonization,
and that's something I'm happy
to speak about a bit more
if there's time,
this kind of idea of
decolonizing the curriculum.
But one of the points that
I do find myself making over
and over in my teaching
is that Britain wasn't the
only the empire of the world
and that empires aren't only ever Western.
Anyway, that may be worth noting.
But given that what non-Western
history is read often
as Imperial history,
area studies can work a little
bit differently as a result
so often I'm surprised to find that people
in the UK think of China
as part of Southeast Asia
instead of East Asia.
Coming from North America,
where you have those
interesting regional boundaries,
that can be interesting to explore,
even though of course,
these categories are themselves,
historically contingent
in all kinds of ways.
But in general, I think
you see ideas of Asia
being tied much more
strongly to South Asia
in really fascinating ways.
And again, I'm happy
to talk about that more
in the Q and A.
Other points to note,
Taoma had mentioned
the points about
things like evaluations of
your research and teaching
being tied to certain kinds
of publications and metrics.
That connects to something in the UK
called the Research Excellence Framework,
the metrication, the ways
in which your publications
are evaluated by your
peers often and regularly.
And this happens every
five years, the REF.
I'm at Cambridge and Cambridge and Oxford
are two universities in
the UK that I would say,
try to
protect their academics from the REF
in all kinds of useful ways,
but it is something that's
important to know about
if you are applying for a job,
because it is something that
you're expected to publish
a certain number of papers
for each REF evaluation,
and so that often
becomes part of planning.
So I don't wanna go on for too long.
I wanna mention very
briefly some challenges
and some positive aspects,
but I will note as well that there are,
well, I'll start with the positive,
which is that
there's just briefly the
costing that I ran up.
So coming to 9,000 pounds for a full visa
and permanent residency.
So one of the wonderful
things about life in the UK
is the particular kind
of academic sociability.
It's a really intense and wonderful
approach to academic life, I
think in all kinds of ways.
And again, I'm happy to
talk about that a bit more
in the Q and A.
But that said, there are challenges.
Life in the UK, in all kinds of ways,
can take a lot to adjust to.
The weather takes a lot to adjust to,
the very, very short
daylight hours in the winter
take a lot to adjust.
As an American working on
Chinese history in the UK,
that effectively means that life is split
between three continents
and that is something that
others might find as well.
Your research and the focus of your study
is in East Asia,
in China, your family
perhaps is in North America
and your job and your life are in Europe.
So it can be complicated by things like
the outbreak of a global pandemic.
There are cultural differences
that people can sometimes laugh about,
the differences in terminology,
but I've been really
struck by the ways in which
you can have a conversation with someone
in the context of British academia,
and as you can see from this
graphic that I've depicted,
what you think is happening
might actually come
across totally differently
to somebody in the British system.
I think I'm keenly aware
that I am running out of
my allotted 12 minutes.
So I just want to note that
there are particular challenges
at the moment in the UK.
I never thought
when I came to to Britain,
that I would be in a position to strike
and to join a union and participate
in an industrial action.
But in 2017
and 2018, and then again last year,
that is what I found myself doing as
part of the Universities
and Colleges Union,
particularly as a part of a
pushback across the sector
against issues with pensions
for UK university staff.
And so that dispute is still ongoing,
but as with many other places,
the working conditions of
teaching staff in the UK
are under constant pressure
from corporatizing interests.
And so that too has been a feature,
not just of my life as an
employee of the university,
but also as a teacher, and
talking through these issues
with my students in
really fascinating way.
So the thing that I will end on
is simply to note that one
of the really lovely benefits
of my time in the UK has been exploring
a really rich world of sources.
I'm so fortunate to be at Cambridge
where the Needham Research
Institute is located,
with a variety of really great archives,
in particular for history of
science and medicine in China.
But there are so many more
sources that I wouldn't have
necessarily been so aware of
if I hadn't been at Cambridge
where there are so many valuable aspects
of things like the national archives,
the foreign office archives,
that shed light on Chinese history,
especially in the 20th century
in really fascinating ways.
So I will stop there, but
thanks very much for your time.
- All right.
This is my turn.
Let me share my screen.
All right. Hi everyone.
Charles Chang, I'm to Duke
Kunshan University or DKU.
I think you've learned a
lot from our other panelists
which showed their institutions in Asia,
and Europe in general.
And I think it will be helpful
if I can briefly introduce my university,
which is a university in China
and which might be quite
different from other universities.
So our university
is a liberal arts university in China,
that is to say it's very different
from the Chinese universities
in that it's completely modeled
after American institutions, namely Duke.
It's very small and competitive,
and it's research oriented.
Generally, it's a joint venture university
setup by Duke University
and
Wuhan University
it is located in Kunshan.
(indistinct)
Kunshan is like a small
country level city.
It has been the richest county in China
for the past 15 years.
So Kunshan has a lot of
advanced manufacturing industry
and the local government
thinks that it would be a great idea
to promote higher education in a sense.
So as a new university,
we enjoyed a generous support
from the local government.
What is DKU's mission?
So Duke Kunshan University, like I said,
is a liberal arts university.
Our mission is to introduce world-class
liberal arts education to China,
and we wanna educate classes
of international talents.
So that is very different
from a traditional Chinese
university that is research-based.
It's very similar to the
liberal arts colleges
in the United States.
We also wanna promote the
innovation of higher education
and support high caliber research
and academic excellence,
and I will talk a little bit about that
in terms of the differences from the DKU
under the American liberal arts colleges.
So in terms of size, we are quite small.
We have 14 undergrad majors,
five masters program.
We have current 130 faculties.
This is in a year of 2019.
And almost at 900 undergrad students.
We're still expanding.
We wanna keep
the faculty and student ratio
to one to six or one to seven.
And then potentially,
we will have about 2,000
undergraduate students,
which means that we will
probably still recruit
a fairly large number of
full-time tenure track faculty.
Like I said, our core mission
is liberal arts education.
So we wanna educate our
undergraduate students
to have a proposal (indistinct)
globally, the (indistinct) that we have.
60% of students come
from all over the world.
So we wanna cultivate
a international culture
where a student can learn from one another
and the undergrad liberal
arts education is a core,
means that we, as a full-time faculty,
we do not get pressure to pursue
academic funding in China,
or publish certain journals
by some kind of metrics.
In a way we are encouraged to do research,
but it's not
mandatory for your tenure case.
And in terms of the
undergraduate education,
we have a bit different structure.
We have couple of features
that are different
from a lot of universities in the US,
in that we have an
intensive seven week term.
So in total, we have four
terms per academic year,
but each term is only seven weeks long.
And for undergrad students,
they normally just take two courses
and they learn all these kinds
of things in seven weeks.
And instead of the department structure,
we have the division or area of knowledge.
So we only have three big divisions,
the Divisions of Arts and Humanities,
Divisions of Social Science
and Division of Natural
and Applied Science.
So that is because we wanna encourage
interdisciplinary studies
so that we do not want
faculty in just one division.
So for the undergrad education,
the students were asked to
take the common core courses,
which includes, for example, the Chinese,
a little bit of the Chinese
history and culture.
And for example,
the philosophical thinking, et cetera.
So in that case, the student
who's educated in a Chinese system
would know more of the
Western ideas and philosophy,
as well as China's place in the world.
And then they also take language courses.
For Chinese students,
they have to take English
courses to improve their English.
And then they were asked
to take divisional courses
and interdisciplinary courses.
And also the undergrad students
normally spend one year
abroad, in a university,
either in the US or,
or other parts of the world.
Most of them went to Duke,
because that is an easy way for them
to get these kinds of credit exchanged.
And then in the fourth year,
they returned to DKU
to continue and to finish their study.
Because we are still new,
so we actually do not have any
undergraduate students
who have graduated yet.
This coming year will be the
first cohort of our students.
So that is the teaching and
the education part of the DKU.
I also wanna give you an idea
about the campus.
So currently we are literally
building our university.
We are going to build
in five phases of the campus,
which in total gonna be
about 200 acres of land,
but currently we have
the phase one completed.
So we will have couple buildings.
They are all designed by
a company that started,
and the buildings are certified by
(indistinct) campus,
so that means we are breathing
kind of like high quality air
that is comparable to
Los Angeles, perhaps.
We are expanding to the phase two.
So this year,
the phase two of the
campus will be complete.
And in the phase two,
we will have libraries,
gymnasium, and as well as
faculty and student apartments.
So in a way,
DKUs gonna be much nicer
in this coming year.
Okay. So in the end, I
wanna talk a little bit
about this hiring process
which you might be very interested in.
So the hiring process at DKU is not very,
very different from the hiring process
in American universities
in that we have three
rounds of the interview.
The first round is just like,
it's conducted remotely.
It's just like any universities in the US.
The second round is the
interview with DKU's leadership.
You will be asked to talk about
your research field into this DKU's
interdisciplinary
environment and how you see
yourself in teaching in terms
of the curriculum at DKU.
The third round is quite different
from what you get in the US in that
we would invite the potential candidates
for a campus visit
during the winter break,
but because normally every year,
for this year, we are hiring 20 to 30
tenure track faculty
since we're expanding.
So we would invite all the candidates
to the campus in the same time.
And this process is not to
create a competitive environment
between candidates, because potentially
if you are like a strong,
you are strong candidates,
DKU can potentially
hire all of them, right?
All of you.
So in a way, this process is rather
trying to observe everyone
in terms of how well
you would work with
existing faculty at DKU
and how you can handle,
for example, teamwork.
So this on-campus visit
will take about two days
where you will give a 15 minutes job talk
and
you also will,
will form a team
to create
sort of a imaginative major
and explain why you wanna do that.
That is a bit different
from the interview process
in the United States.
And once you get hired, DKU offers
competitive salary
and the startup fund
and the generous benefits
comparable to the US institutions.
The typical teaching load
is,
the typical teaching load is
five courses per academic year.
However, currently we are
under four teaching,
four courses per academic year
and the teaching's a bit flexible.
So in that case,
you could arrange on your teaching
into two semesters that
are most convenient for you
and spend some time
for your own research.
And lastly,
okay.
So lastly,
I wanna see that
in terms of applying to the jobs at DKU,
sometimes
people don't realize that
that unlike the application in the US
where you have to be very
clear fate to a position,
sometimes, because DKU's expanding
so DKU's waiting to be
a little bit flexible
in terms of the job applications.
So if you're a strong candidate
and you see a position
that is related to you,
however, may not be extremely related,
you still should apply
because in a way,
maybe DKU could fit you
into another position
that they are trying to expand to.
So, in a way, there's
a possibility that if
the position that you're applying
is not completely a clear fate to you.
Last, I wanna mention that I
really enjoy teaching at DKU,
strangely, because here the
students are highly motivated
and they are eager to learn.
Even in a field of
humanities, people are very,
students are very interested.
Also, the staff is highly motivated.
I've never received email reply
more than 24 hours at DKU.
All the staff try to be very helpful.
And in the end, also, my
colleagues are very young as well,
and I very much enjoy the environment
where everybody's trying to
build their academic career.
Of course, we have many problems,
especially during this COVID
pandemic as a young university.
However, I think the academic environment
is very encouraging,
and at least I enjoy this young
and the invigorating environment.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much to
all of our panelists.
I deeply enjoyed all of your,
all of your presentations
and recruiting style as well.
We have some questions in
the Q and A and in the chat.
If you did ask a question in the chat,
please go ahead and move it to Q and A
since we'll focus on those.
We'll start with a few questions
that address all the panelists,
and then we'll go to questions that focus
on particular individuals.
So the first question from our audience
is a two-part question for everyone.
Why did you apply for
jobs outside of the US
and does your future plan
involve returning to the US
in an academic capacity?
- Well, I can get started.
When I graduated, I applied everywhere.
So I landed in Singapore,
largely because that was
the only offer I received.
And I think one of the reasons,
I didn't get the talk about it,
but I think Singapore, Asia, in general
is a good environment for working mothers,
especially academics with small children
in the sense that
childcare is less expensive
and it's affordable to
hire helpers or nannies.
So I do find that
a big attraction for me.
Another thing I think
is that close to family
because I was born and raised in China.
My parents, are now in Shenzhen,
it's only four hours flight away.
So for me, I think
it's whether going,
my friends always ask me
are you planning to go back to the US.
In my case, probably for family reasons,
not in the foreseeable future.
I'd be happy to hear
what the other colleague.
- Yeah, I can go next.
So when I apply my apply positions,
I also applied everywhere.
I got 16 job interviews
in the United States
for tenure track positions.
I have two job offers in
the end, but I choose DKU.
I think I got some difficulties in the US
because my background is
a bit interdisciplinary
and normally in the US,
the difficulty is that if
you are interdisciplinary,
you have to try really hard to fit into
a department environment,
which it's very difficult for me.
So in the end,
I feel that a lot of positions in the US
were not a good fit for me.
And also, I spend a lot of,
pretty much most of my academic
career in United States.
And
last year when I applied jobs at DKU,
I feel like because I studied China
and I spend too much time in the US,
I feel my research is a bit out of parts
in a way that I do need to
do some kind of field work
to get to know the
situation on the ground.
So I decided to move back to China.
I have families back in a
Wisconsin, United States.
So I do visit my family.
As to the future, I don't know.
I think it all depends on my research.
If I think it's a good idea to move,
then I will.
But so far I've been
having a good time in China
and I'm happy not to move.
- So maybe I can go next quickly
and just say why I decided to apply.
Like everyone else, I applied everywhere
and I was really, really lucky
in that basically my dream job
in the best department that
I could hope for came up
the year that I was applying.
And I got really, really lucky.
And I am someone who trained
in a history of science program,
and so for me to be able to get a job
in a department of history
and philosophy of science,
the chances of that were vanishingly rare.
So for me to be able to continue to work
in an academic community
that was organized around
that field of the history of science,
was really, really precious.
And so for me, that was absolutely why
it was barely a decision
to have to make, to apply.
And then, yeah.
So that's really,
my answer is that,
that was what I would have,
the best I could have
really hoped for, I think.
Yeah.
- Thank you all for those responses.
We have a question from
Kayhan Nahaad who says,
"Thank you for this
very informative panel.
How can scholars studying topics
outside the bounds of East Asian
and Southeast Asian studies
position themselves
competitively for employment
in these regions?"
Or maybe how about for
employment at your institution?
- Okay, I can get started since
he mentioned Southeast Asia.
So for Singapore,
Singapore has been a
very cosmopolitan place,
but I think after pandemic,
we see similar trends all around the world
is becoming more insular.
So that tendency also affect
how you position yourself
when applying for a job in Singapore.
So for Southeast Asianers,
I think it's generally,
Singapore is generally very
friendly to Southeast Asianers
because Southeast Asia
is strategically important to Singapore,
How you can tailor your project,
for example, if you can
effectively tailor your project
to some of the governmental
agendas in Singapore,
meaning, for example, smart cities,
urban development, science and technology,
intra Asia regional connectivity,
I think these are the key words.
So for example,
I mentioned earlier my
colleague, Florence Mark
who recently got his Nanyang
assistant professorship,
I think she's very savvy
in framing her project,
not just as about Hong Kong,
it's about decolonization,
and it's also about urban development
in the global cities of Asia.
So definitely, cager it more towards
some of the official agenda in Singapore
is very important.
Not just for a job classification,
but also for grant application as well.
- I can go next.
So to DKU,
I don't think studying
something outside of Asia
is a problem because we
sometimes intentionally hire
faculty who teaches
on areas outside of Asia.
For example, we have faculty
who teach American politics,
and that is appealing part
because we try to promote
international higher education
and our students are very
interested in knowledge.
Something like even
Judaism or even
European history.
So in a way, it's not a disadvantage
if you study something
that is not based in Asia.
- Maybe I can follow the same order
as the previous question.
So just for the part of
the UK, to be honest,
I think my advice on this question
would be to just pay very close attention
to the department or faculty
that is advertising the job,
which I realize is quite general advice,
but I think it's particularly applicable
in a case like Cambridge
or other UK universities
where the institutional
configurations can be very unique.
So for example, at Cambridge,
the history faculty, up until recently,
had one person working on Southeast Asia
who connected to various aspects
of overseas Chinese communities.
Rachel Leo who's worked,
I'm sure I'm underselling
in all kinds of ways,
but most of the teaching
and what we would consider Asian history
was happening in the faculty
of Asian and middle Eastern studies.
So a totally different faculty
and I think possibly
even a separate school
within the university.
And there wasn't any,
my position was created de novo, new,
in history and philosophy of science.
So,
really, I think it's
probably just a lesson
to think carefully about
the department that's
advertising the position
and how your work would fit
into the existing faculty's
research interests and themes
really as much as anything.
- Thank you. We actually
have two questions
about where you find job
announcements outside of the US
so I wonder if we could go around
and just in a quick
list, name the top sites
where you found postings
about either your positions
or international positions.
- So I think we all check on the H-Net.
I've been away from the job market a while
so I'm not familiar with H-Net,
but I agree, some of the
universities outside the US
are not very consistent
with posting all their jobs
on this platform,
so I'd be happy to send the
links to the two positions
I talk about at my home institution.
And another thing I
recently thought very useful
is academic Twitter.
So lots of job posts.
I got notified on Twitter in firsthand.
- Yes,
I did the same thing.
I look at jobs at H-Net
and I also joined a lot of mailing lists,
as well as looking
through this job posting
different kind of associations website.
Also, I just use Google a lot.
Actually, there is a lot of jobs
if you just search your field
and is in tenure track on Google,
and that would pop up
a lot of information.
So I look at that as well.
- So there's one website
for UK academic jobs
where I think all of them are posted,
which is jobs.ac.uk,
and that gives you a
smorgasbord of different options
and you can filter it as needed,
but that's what I would
normally direct people to
for looking at UK positions.
- Thank you so much for this.
I see that we're almost out of time.
I was thinking that perhaps
we could ask one teaching
and one research question that
any one of you can respond to if you like,
it doesn't have to be everyone.
But we have a question from Joshua Tan.
What are some of the
challenges and opportunities
regarding teaching or course
design for non-US contexts?
In other words,
are
the syllabi that you've
designed in the US,
are they relevant and
how did you adapt yours?
- I think being Asia allow
you to teach more niche topics
because the students have,
they really have a good
background knowledge
about the region
in the pre-university level education.
For example, I teach topics
such as Modern Indonesia,
World War II in Southeast Asia.
This topic probably are
not really pragmatic
in the Western context,
but in terms of the general curriculum
such as introduction to Asia Pacific,
I found it really interesting to re-frame
some of the debates and topics in the Asia
context, in the sense that
what we teach, what we
research are usually framed by
the political discourse,
or the larger political
context where we're situated.
So it's kind of fun
to rework all these frameworks
and reshape the, for
example, discussion question
or debate topics.
But I think the general,
in the question,
what you read or work on
during your qualifications,
that's still very useful,
but you probably need to
frame it in a different way.
- Thank you. Does anybody else
wanna chime in on teaching?
- I was just gonna briefly say that
teaching at Cambridge, and more generally,
in the Oxford system
is so weird and unusual
that I had to learn a whole new vocabulary
where students aren't in years,
they're in part two or part three.
And I think for me,
the biggest change was
giving many fewer lectures
and therefore having to squeeze
and compress a lot more
material very quickly,
especially because the very
specialized nature of the UK
educational system means that
students only study a few topics
before going to university.
And so they have a lot of
really intense knowledge
about several topics,
but not necessarily a
breadth of knowledge,
not necessarily very much
knowledge at all about
Asia or Asian history in particular.
So that can be a challenge,
but also really fascinating and
rewarding in different ways.
- Thank you so much.
- [Denise] Thank you so much.
- I think for me,
it's because China and
the US are so different,
so sometimes my students
do not know certain things
that have been censored
by the Chinese government.
So in my class I would
actually teach them.
I would mention things
like Tiananmen Square event
among other things.
And I would encourage my students
to use Google and stuff instead of Baidu
if you can imagine that they're in China.
Other than that,
actually, I find that students
are really interesting
once they started to
learn this kind of stuff,
they feel very, I guess inspired
and that they tend to ask me a lot
of questions about
things that were taught
either in Chinese history
or in a Western philosophy
or something like that.
And that part
is a great rewarding experience for me.
- Thank you so much for
sharing those experiences.
Let's ask a final research question
that I will tag on a couple
of the individual questions.
So an anonymous attendee
asks about human subjects,
research infrastructure
protocol in your institution.
For example, if you use
ethnographic methods.
So that's a question
directly for the whole panel.
- I think doing research in
China's great because in a way
you can do your field work all the time
by just talking to people
and trying different kinds of things.
The recent crack down on academia
does not really affect us much.
Frankly, when we designed DKU,
I learned that
we pretty much wanna protect
academic freedom at DKU.
Meaning that you teach
whatever you like to teach
and in the end, DKU will defend you
if that is thing is problematic
by the Chinese government.
But of course, we are
speaking outside of DKU.
You will have to take a personal risk
in terms of what you say and what you do,
but my experience is that
I do research on religion.
For example, early this year,
I visited (indistinct)
et cetera, et cetera,
and I didn't find it problematic at all.
So in a way, I mean,
if you learn those kinds
of things over time,
you would understand little bit better
about the boundaries there.
In terms of
the kind of research environment
regarding to the IRB,
we are trying to innovate
IRB a little bit.
We try to keep the IRB as rigorous,
just like in a US institutions,
just because we have to protect
human subjects in general,
especially in China,
but we also wanna innovate
in case you do something with regard to,
for example, social media
cause,
you know,
the American system did not
probably heard enough about
IRB regarding to social media as well.
So if you do something
related to social media
and the computation on DKU,
you will get probably
a speedier IRP process
compared to that same
process in the United States,
just because we had some new
innovations regarding that.
- Well we have gone over time
so I think I'm going to wrap this up.
But once again,
I would like to thank all
of our wonderful panelists
for their super informative
and very interesting talks.
We'd like to thank the
Council on East Asian Studies,
especially Stephanie Kim and Richard Sosa
for providing all the staffing
and support for this event.
And of course, we would
like to thank all of you
for tuning in.
So thank you to all of our supporters
for making this summer
webinar series a huge success.
All the best for the rest of your summers.
And hopefully we will
see you again next year.
So take care, everyone.